believe and feel reflecting back but
first we're going to start with you know
some of the background that led each of
them to play the roles that they did in
the Good Friday agreement and let me
start if I could Tony with you
um I think it's fair to say that when
you became prime minister for many
people in the UK but far beyond the UK
the Northern Ireland troubles
had seemed insoluble that they were
really bred in the bone that there was
very little that could make a difference
so what made you as prime minister
coming in with a big agenda because I
can I remember your first election there
was a lot of things you wanted to do and
talked about during the campaign to
believe that
there could be some resolution of the
troubles and that you wanted to do
everything you could to explore that
and first of all um thank you very much
indeed for having me here uh at queens
and to be alongside President Clinton
and the teacher bertia hernu the two
people who did so much to help bring the
Good Friday agreement about and this is
my first time ever to be interviewed by
you by the way so I'm slightly
familiar they're all a little nervous if
you haven't noticed yeah
[Applause]
especially the panelists in the middle
follow-ups that'll get him in trouble
well I I I that's that's the voice of
experience so I should listen to it so
um
we came to power obviously and it's
important to say this I mean John Major
had tried uh hard hit he started a a
process John human had been a constant
arguer that it was possible
and I mean John I remember you know when
I was in the House of Commons as the
leader of the opposition and in
Parliament when you're going through the
the voting lobbies
John Hume would wait strategically for
me as I was going through the lobbyist
and he would back me into a corner and
John was someone who who was very
persuasive but
you know there weren't short
conversations right so
but the thing that he drove home to me
the whole time was that it was possible
he said I know people tell you it's
impossible it's possible and then I I
was explaining to people earlier my own
family background obviously my mother
was from Donegal in Ireland but even
though living in the Republic they
they've been a Protestant family and I'd
grown up with her the trouble has been
very much parted by my youth and my my
own personal history so I was determined
for all sorts of reasons to try to do
things
and then actually as leader of the
opposition
I met 30 at her at that time I think but
you first time I met you went uh the the
teacher and I also kind of felt when I
had that conversation with Bertie
there was there was something I felt
that could be done that there was a you
know we were coming up to the the end of
the 20th century or a new millennium
there was a new generation taking charge
in various places
um obviously we were huge fans of of
what President Clinton and yourself were
doing in the U.S everything kind of
aligned and so and maybe this was just
also the fact that we were new in
government and hadn't had time to become
cynical
so we just thought now let's give this a
go and I remember discussing it with one
of my
my Deputy Prime Minister John Prescott
who said to me I don't know why you're
doing this he said they absolutely hate
each other over there you know
I'm gonna give it a go and so we did um
and uh yeah that's I I
felt
and I suppose there always this this
moment in time when things seem to come
together and and so at least I thought
it was worth giving it the best shot I
think it's also important the role that
relationships uh played and the story
you just told about John Hume uh really
illustrates that and earlier in one of
the panels uh Jerry Adams was talking
about how he and John who began a
conversation even like I think it was 12
years before uh the Good Friday
agreement and you know John's
genuineness his authentic spirit and
heart were just contagious weren't they
I mean you you couldn't not listen to
John Hume with his passionate belief in
the goodness of people and the potential
for peace without going away shaking
your head yes it's possible
but I also think you reference the
relationship with uh Bertie Ahern too
and
you know as someone who had the benefit
of observing uh all three of you
um you really each had a unique
political and personal capacity uh to
connect with others and birdie
particularly had a a real skill with
that and and so birdie when you became
t-shock after having been in politics
obviously having observed what was
happening in the north
um how did you think about whether there
was a path forward
well I suppose the troubles have gone on
so long and
um all of us Albert Reynolds be before
me John Major you know it was just an
issue you felt you had to try and of
course you're meeting all the all the
party leaders and it you know it's
meeting John meeting Jerry and meeting
and all of the political leaders and and
I was lucky enough to meet you and
president when you came over in 95 I was
leader of the opposition so I I I was to
get 10 minutes with you up in the um and
the ambassador's residents of Phoenix
Park and you give me an hour and you
obviously nothing to do that day but
anyway
and then I I have gotten not only well
and we had met in Dublin we've met an
aggressive Motel was the first time I've
met Tony and we met in in in
um
and in both parliaments uh so I I felt
in all this and this was worth it and
Tony had made it very clear he was going
to give this a real crack his first
speech even though he you know was a
huge celebrations coming in as the labor
prime minister you know huge crowds and
the first thing he did was come to
Northern Ireland so we couldn't show
more serious intent than that he went to
the Balmoral agricultural show and
um my job
he has a big farmer in checkers as well
but but we we we got working on it and I
think you know we went back and
met you Jerry waiting was to get the
ceasefire back on track and and to get
get moving so I think from then on you
know from that summer of 97 all the way
up to Good Friday like it it seemed like
every day but it was certainly every
week I hold the record which will never
be beaten of the Irish Prime Minister
and Irish teacher that was in number 10
more than anywhere else I can tell you
that I was there every week and the food
was always golden like Castle buildings
so I think that's how it got going so
the relationship was good and and of
course president whenever whenever and
ever we need the church sometimes it
said you set up on like the last few
days but the reality was you were you
were there all the time for us and I
think that's how the relationship
developed
so um Bill you also have
um an interesting Pathway to the
decision to become so actively involved
and and working with Tony and Bertie and
eventually asking George Mitchell to
serve as your Envoy and uh be deeply
involved can you give us a sort of you
know timeline if you will of how you
ended up working with Tony and Bertie
and being so uh committed to trying to
resolve the troubles
first of all I think
whatever your politicians like us talk
you shouldn't discount what we say
but you should try to make sure you got
the contacts right
that is
almost everything you do if particularly
if you win an election
and you have executive responsibilities
is a combination of something you care
about
uh
something people people you care about
ask you to do
and then you have to figure out how
you're going to do it and survive
and all this stuff seems so
straightforward today and easy and it
wasn't
I mean
I got interested in this
when I came to Oxford in 1968 and the
trouble started in 69 and Bernadette
devil was uh
it was a
attractive young woman who got elected
to Parliament and all the kids liked her
we didn't know Jack about the visit
a lot of us but it got
people thinking about our in a different
way
and then All the Troubles happened and
they were happening when I was there
and then over the years when I would
go back to the UK or to
Ireland
I would keep up and
then when I was running
for president
uh
knew that I had to be up to date on the
Irish issue when I went to New York to
the primary when I went to Massachusetts
and
uh
this big group in New York asked me to
come to a meeting and my opponents were
there the ones that were left by the
time we got to New York
and
so it looked like I was going to win the
nomination if I didn't screw it up
and then
but there was this big attempt to derail
and there were people think oh well you
don't want to take any chances
but I had some people working with me
and people I'd gotten to know were part
of the Irish Community in New York who
actually
thought I should agree to appoint a
special Envoy which then was Harrison
that's before they're running Pizza
officer George Mitchell the mediator
and uh
I got there late one night everybody
else
who was trying to beat me and already
put in their best shot
and
they asked and I made up my mind I said
all right I'm not going to bring this up
but if they ask I'm going to tell them
the truth yes I will apply a special
online
and they told me they said you have no
idea how hard this is going to be for
you to keep this commitment
people will think you're insane
the state department had operated for
decades under the theory that our
relationship with the UK was so
important we couldn't mess it up even
President Kennedy and his heralded visit
to Ireland did not go to the north and
did not talk about it
and
you know this was one of those things
that wasn't done
well I thought it was crazy
to deny
such a large problems existence
and to take a pass when we had the
biggest Irish to ask for we had people
who were part of the a big Irish
population that were pro-units
as well as the
people that filled
the bars and other places in Boston and
New York who were
Republicans
and
so they asked me what'd you do this and
I said yes
and it sounds good then you have to do
it
and
then everybody was telling me why I
shouldn't do it
and Nancy soderberger was on the
previous panel here
she was on my national security staff
and she and Tony like
and Sandy Berger
they favored
naming a special honor
and everybody else thought I was crazy
the British press was so bad that they
were speculating that John Major I just
did it to burn John Major because he
checked my passport files for the Bush
campaign in 92.
like I was changed all American policy
just even today there are people
spiteful enough to do that but I was
I was too dumb to think like that
but everybody's going nothing oh my God
they're
Clinton is so pissed off at Major
I'm checking his passport files to see
if he tried to give up his citizenship
to join the Soviet Union
they uh
that's the only reason he's doing this
and it was like just that's how
inconceivable it was to the whole
British Barney politic
and I told you and I respected it told
him he said I respected it made your
tribe because he was on a very thin
parliamentary majority and he needed the
unionist
members of parliament
and he risked anyone
and even though it was the point I
didn't really go anywhere he tried and I
think we should all give him credit for
trying
[Applause]
and the tea shop at the time Albert
Reynolds thought I should Grant
Jerry avisa
and
so we all worked it out there were seven
Irish groups and
and
mostly based in New York City that
wanted him to come
and one of them sponsored a conference
they put together a whole speech deal
and he asked for a Visa and we agreed so
I could
like the United States looked like an
impartial body that I would Grant a Visa
for two days but there would be no
fundraising
and everybody knew that a lot of money
was going into Ireland from the
Northeast United States especially but
not on this trip we were going to send a
signal that we wanted to be involved but
we wanted it to be positive and we want
to be fair
and uh
we have two people who are members of
Congress here now at least said
uh
Richard Neal the chairman of the
housewives that needs committee and
Marty men
who years ago became president of the
University of Massachusetts but he was
there then
and Peter King called me
to wish me well but before I left it
became my best Republican supporter
because he was from limerick
and his mother said if you try to run
that president out of office I'll never
speak to you again
So eventually there were certain
benefits
but at the time it was crazy
they thought I thought it made all the
sense in the world because what we were
doing is not working and it seemed to me
just from The Talk
that the public was maybe way ahead of
the politicians in their desire
to have some sort of resolution of this
so I gave Jerry the Visa
and
he kept his word as he always did in
dealing with me and
the rest is history
and it brought me closer to Tony and he
was interested it meant a lot to me
because I loved it when he won on his
whole campaign platform you know was
basically consistent with what I
believed and he and Cherie and Hillary
and I had an interesting dinner together
not long after he became
and then
I met
birdie and I thought you know Bernie had
to kind of BS and I always wished I had
it
I want to be burning when I grow up
so we all got along and that's a big
deal if you trust somebody
because if you make enough decisions
under this kind of pressure with all
these changing circumstances
some of your decisions will be wrong or
will be questioned or will not be good
for one of your partners on any given
day it just happens you can't nobody's
perfect you can't foresee all this and
the fact that we trusted each other
and we trust that eventually I think we
earn the trust of the parties of
Northern Ireland that we were dealing
with pretty much across the board
because they thought we would be
straight with them
and that's how it happens
and it
it turned out to be
you know there were days when I felt
like I was award politician
in Chicago Hillary's Hometown and there
were days I felt like I was taking
Seamus heaney's advice if just
take a flying leap and
walk on air against your better judgment
so
but that's how I started
we all just decided that the time was
right to do the right thing
there were a zillion there are lots of
people here who were involved in this
from all our including General chessler
who had to oversee the decommissioning
of Arts which was highly controversial
at the time people thought we were crazy
to think it could ever be done I
remember the first time it brought up
and
so we were all out here just
we'd like to tell you that we had it all
thought through but the truth is we made
up a lot of it as we went along we had
to win
and then when Mitchell came in
he organized our efforts
well again I think
I I think the importance of
relationships the importance of building
trust
um just really our key to everything
that happened afterwards
um so Tony you made this kind of leap of
faith that you were going to be
committed to doing everything that you
could
as you began that effort
what did you have in mind where where
did you think your commitment was going
to lead
um in Northern Ireland
yeah just before I come to I should say
I I was also very grateful to to
um President Clinton because he
he was very good to me even when I was
leader of the opposition
and in particular I know you probably
don't even remember this but when I was
leader of the opposition that I
got the chance to go and meet the
president of the United States now when
you're the leader of the opposition of
the UK you go meet the president United
States the visit's got to go well okay
it's going to go well so I'm running up
to my election
and
the president was about to seek
re-election in the U.S so I go and see
him in the Oval Office that's a great
thing
and we're sitting there in those two
chairs like you do in the in the Oval
Office and they bring the press in a
great scrap
the old press come in
and you know what the British media is
like so you're always a little you know
what's gonna happen so they come in big
scrum and someone throws the question to
President Clinton they say Mr President
do you think you're sitting alongside
the next British prime minister
and I completely freeze because I think
what can he say because he he can't say
yes because that would be undiplomatic
in this young major
on the other hand if he says no
you know the business's not gone so well
right so he says I just hope he's
sitting alongside the next president of
the United States
[Applause]
I always thought yeah that guy could do
premises questions so
when when
we began this we the first thing we did
and I think this is a really important
element for any peace process is we
agreed to talk to everybody
and you know in the end with with the
peace process in Northern Ireland
I mean okay we have difficult jobs to do
but the people with the really difficult
jobs whether politicians in Northern
Ireland because they were taking risks
and they were also having to say to
their own supporters
who had built up a narrative over a long
period of time
we're going to change strategy we're
going to move we're going to do things
differently and so you know for the
Triple he had to make
you know this was a really really
difficult set of decisions he had today
uh Shameless Mallard and then of course
fishing feign as well
um and then you had loyalist groups so a
whole range of different people all of
whom were gonna have to take difficult
decisions to move this process along and
I think the most important thing
starting point for this is that we were
prepared to go and talk to everybody and
I remember I mean Jerry will remember
this well I mean the first meeting I had
with with Shin Fame with Jerry Adams
Mark McGinnis I mean at the time this
was you know very shocking to people and
you had to be prepared to do it and I
remember after I did it I um with people
and he would call this I I then after I
met them for the first time
I then went to a shopping center for a
visit you know you do you meet and then
you go for a visit and
I told you about this last night when
when I got the shopping center I got in
there I was saying hello to people and
so on and then suddenly there was this
this huge wave of people including
people who are wearing washing up gloves
you know there's there's a plastic
washing out gloves
and
you know the last time I'd ever seen
anyone where this is my mum and I was
kind of
they're all coming together I think
what's going on here what sort of
protest is it but this was all to do
with the fact that I shouldn't have been
shaking hands with Jerry Adams because
this is a big thing you see that you
people were saying there was a huge
debate yes you can beat them but you
can't shake hands of them I said we're
going to meet him we're going to shake
hands let's just let's just do what you
would do one human being to another and
let's see what we can go we know we
disagree about the past but let's see if
we can agree about the future
and you know Mom then went and visited
the loyalist prisoners uh in the Maze
all of these things were difficult I
don't think anything could have happened
unless we were prepared to sit down and
talk to people and to understand these
conflicts come about because there are
two distinct narratives in opposition to
each other and the only way you will
ever make peace is if one side
understands how the other side feel they
don't have to agree with it they don't
even have to sympathize with it but at
least they have to understand it
and
[Applause]
thank you
I I think that's
a lesson that we should all
not only here but repeat to ourselves
and others because clearly you don't
make peace with your friends you don't
make peace with people that you already
agree with you have to keep searching
for that Common Ground
so birdie when when
you realize that there was going to be a
serious commitment from the Blair
government and then that the United
States was you know then President
Clinton would also be engaged how were
you thinking about what needed to happen
in order for this to work because you
had literally lived with it you've
watched it you knew a lot of the players
um
and so you had a had a ringside seat for
years but all of a sudden it looks like
it might be real and you had to figure
out what you could do and how you could
support it
we got a few lucky breaks I will say we
decided September 97 that the talks were
going to start
and it didn't start too good because the
first day we said listen Mitchell
principles who can't be involved in
violence and you can't be in in the
peace talks so everyone signed up to the
major principles and so that was good so
champagne were coming into the into the
talks you'll never guess what happened
and to do your P walked out and look
but In fairness to Gary McMichael and
Don Curtis who are here they walked back
in with David Trimble and so In fairness
today Patrol that was a brave move and I
think he deserves anything
[Applause]
so we got going in okay I think George
gave a good explanation at the day of
what happened over those months and you
know it was up and down and up and down
but I think the two things that Tony and
I did that you know that talks were as
inclusive as we possibly could make them
everyone was in the wanted to be in we
continued trying to get everybody in
which we did by Saint Andrews took us a
while but
um and then was as comprehensive as
possible and I think all the issues were
on the table you know very difficult
issues and you know issues that I think
people thought were impossible to do
with
decommissioning prisoners performing
Rhino constabulary changing a lot of the
legislation I mean there were huge
issues and I keep thinking today when
you look at the issues today but I know
we won't get into today's issues but
there were huge huge dishes and the fact
that everybody kept going In fairness of
parties like we totally were you know
Tony has said about the parties they had
to to make their their individual breaks
I of course knew that the big thing we
were going to have to do because we had
1937 constitutionally claimed
jurisdiction over Northern Ireland an
arc that's two and three were were very
special you know maybe not to to me but
my father who was an old Ira man and my
mother who loved Tony Blair but didn't
like everybody from that ended the world
and
so there were difficult choices but we
all had to do something and I think that
was that that was the issue that
everybody everybody
um the talkest time the talk over that
winter
autumn you know Autumn winter into the
springtime but everybody knew they had
to make tough decisions and the reality
was that everybody did and I think that
was the great thing about delivery the
people were prepared to say well we have
our bit to do and the governments are
doing their bit the president of the
United States is doing his best and if
we all do it together comprehensive
inclusive process then it's for the
betterment the Northern Ireland and
amazingly that that's how it would say
that
this morning
um
Senator Mitchell said there would not
have been a peace process without John
Hume and there would not have been a
peace agreement without David Trimble
and I think that uh you know it's it's
really important especially because
they're no longer with us to to remember
the roles that each of them played but
every person at the table everybody
involved in the process
um
I think it's fair to say was a unique uh
personality and leader and trying to
work through all of their concerns their
personal experiences uh their grievances
their hopes all of that was so uh
difficult as you said Bernie because you
know it was so inclusive but by being
inclusive you had to bring everybody
literally to the table and then to an
agreement
and you know Bill part of what I know
you did was to work
um to develop personal relationships
with a lot of the leaders so that
um you could call them they would be
invited to Washington for the St
Patrick's Day
celebration at the White House other
kinds of events could could you talk a
little bit about how you and George
Mitchell discussed managing such a big
process such an inclusive process and
how you build trust with people who
start off from such different
perspectives
first when we started talking about this
and especially after Iraq the visa to
Jerry
then everybody settled down whether they
were Foreigner against it they said well
maybe America is serious and we need to
be consultant you know
you know so I try to meet with as many
as I could and then we we used St
Patrick's Day
as a excuse if you will that annual
White House ceremony
to invite people there and then to
either get them to talk to each other or
get them to talk to me individually
until we could get everybody together
but we
we try to find venues in which people
would feel comfortable
not embarrassed and could get cover if
they needed
and I think that's important because
yes it's important people talk to each
other but they have to be able to say
what they think
and outline what the
problems are and one of the things I
must say
that I had almost no experience with
before I got up to my ears and this was
multi-party democracies you know because
we have too many parties in America and
usually if a third party gets going it's
main consequence is to screw things up
from one of the two main parts because
they can't ever win enough votes in our
system to get a Where the wild
you know very few
Senate seats or congressional seats or
governorships
so
I was
literally fascinated for you the whole
time I was there for eight years I was
passing it
but why people were in what party
and what it meant to them
and I found that every single one of
them that I talked to had a good reason
that went well beyond any kind of
personal ambition
that they I I have belong to this party
because of hey I belong to that worry
because of me and I found it
incredibly enlightening
and I found that if we were making
Headway
with some of the parties that might not
have had
such big numbers
it still affected the chemistry
because we had a reputation for
listening and trying to respond to
problems and
but we did a lot in because of St
Patrick's Day and then we did a lot when
I went places and
and I was
talking to Tony and
Bernie all the time
and then
once in a while even in the beginning
Mitchell would give me marching orders
when I were absolutely knew what he has
you know I want to go to that last week
the push because earlier it was
mentioned that both you Tony and you
birdie actually came to Belfast
can each of you describe what that last
week was like because in retrospect it
seems like such a high wire Act and the
fact that it all came together at the
end is nothing short of a miracle but
you were so both of you so
intensely involved and take the audience
sort of behind the scenes of what that
those last days were like
well for dirty I should say two they
were particularly difficult person
because you lost your mother I think
just this is the process began and it
came straight back afterwards which was
enormously helpful I just want to say
this about 30 as well he
he had that
it's a great political ability if you
have this
I mean he took lots of abuse during the
course of this process I mean people
would come and be really rude to them I
I get offended on his behalf but he was
never really offended he was shrugging
shoulders and said they can say whatever
they like we just got to get the deal
done and it's a really interesting
anyway
I've always wanted to say publicly
properly thank you because
[Applause]
it
was a
it was a roller coaster all the way
through
but we had
alongside the the individual decisions
that leaders have to make we had a
framework
that people thought was essentially Fair
that framework was the principle of
consent on the one side the Northern
Ireland should remained part of the UK
as long as the majority of people in
Northern Ireland wanted it and on the
other side that there should be Fairless
Injustice and a recognition that there
hadn't been and therefore the
institutions of Northern Ireland had to
change
and I think you never
get an agreement unless
there is at the heart of it
almost intellectually and politically
something that people think is is fair
and the thing about politics that you
find is
it's always a battle of Reason against
unreason right it's always when you take
a step back and you put all the
prejudices and all the background and
all the history behind you what is the
sensible Sensible solution right if you
can Define that and create it then the
rest is strategy and tactics to get
there and I think that was a very very
important part of it also we were
to be absolutely Frank as we carry on
during the days and nights and as George
Mitchell was just saying they were days
and nights I mean we've got a few hours
sleep the whole time
then frankly one thing that that
happened in this was that there came a
sort of strange collected spirit that
said at the end of this we can't go out
there and say anyway it didn't work
because the whole of the world's media
but then camped outside and I confessed
I was starting to get a little bit
nervous of uh
you know the political consequences of
failure but this is a good thing because
it was a Spur to carry on working at it
and you know as the other thing is that
it was
it was up and I mean
switching allergies it was a seesaw the
whole time right sir
suddenly one side would be completely
against it and then you had to try and
bring the thing back into equilibrium
again then the other side would be
completely against it and then
you know I was describing to people
earlier how
if you were in a room with a group of
people and they were the next meeting
was waiting to come in from the other
side
I realized after a time you couldn't
have them walk out because if they
walked out looking happy the other
people came in sad and said this is a
total disaster for the negotiation
so
but the other thing was that you had
it echoes something that the bill was
saying America
you had
the established the relationship where
you could have what I call a strategic
conversation
right so when I was dealing with David
or or with Jerry birthday and I would be
sitting there doing a lot of the
meetings together right so there was no
you know the British and Irish
government sitting there together was
itself an important thing
we were able to have a strategic
conversation by that I mean
they tell you honestly what their
problem is then you try honestly to
solve it
and it's a really important thing
because if you can't have that
properly Frank exchange of where you
really are in the whole thing you can't
solve the problem right because people
just either stick in their positions or
they don't trust you enough to say look
I don't want me to do this but I can't
however I might be able to do that so
you're always looking for that way
through and anyway for three days it was
like this Castle buildings is uh I mean
is it still standing there
they should I mean it's it should be a
sort of um
Monument to the wrong type of
architecture but it's
so we were in this terrible building the
facilities were terrible everything was
absolutely terrible and then
you know and every song Moe who always
had a sense of humor about these things
every song when things were really
really Grim she'd say to me
you're really depressed aren't you and
I'd say yeah I'm really depressing time
for the women's coalition
thank you
hey we've come to women's Coalition I
say these people are really reasonable
that's the future now let's get back to
the present so
um yeah it was it was a strange
psychology uh and and in the end
when I had the final call with David
Trimble and I think Billy dorsa just
spoken he by the way I was calling him
I mean I mean I used to call him I
ignored the time zone so I sometimes I
was calling it must have been three or
four in the morning and you know they
put me through and you say hi Hi how are
you going and if you stood down the
phone and said to Jonathan this guy
asleep I mean it's like three in the
morning in the US they win so we had the
final call with
with David triple then we
then we just went for it but I think it
it was
it was a combination of many things
but in the end I come back to the same
thing you can have whatever technical
agreement
that you like
but if the spirit is not sitting
alongside it it will never work
[Applause]
that is so true and birdie what are your
Recollections of uh that intense period
well can I thank Tony for remembering my
mind because that
but you know I think we'd set out that
last week
and it was going to be intense it was
going to be you know it's just a huge
range of meetings of trying to get
people to uh to move a bit and move her
in there and of course like everything
you plan the week out you said well you
know some ends of this would be easy and
some ends will be difficult and then by
the time we got to Monday you realize
you were wrong everything was difficult
and and then you'll go up and down I got
the call I also remember
and my own civil servants around me when
was coming out of the church when my
mother's removal and
um they said listen we have to talk to
George Mitchell this is losing his hair
and then and I don't think much of it at
the time either but he he was definitely
um fed up with with everybody and he he
said listen strand too has driven the
the union is mad and John Taylor has
just said that he wouldn't touch it with
a party for Paris Paul and he said you
know you're gonna have to get up here so
I said well how am I going to get up
here so anyway we worked it out and I
went for this walk and George wish I
forgotten I went for a walk down
Griffith Avenue which is one of the
longest streets in Europe and after
about at the start of a George said
we're arguments in Griffith Avenue and
about an hour and a half later he said
very endlessly
[Laughter]
foreign
I met Tony and we met in Hillsborough
where we got food and which we didn't
know last night and Castle buildings it
got hurt and stuff but anyway but Tony
gave me a lovely breakfast I went to
Canada Trimble
um and the 14-foot pole was put to the
side and
um then I remember going to to Jerry and
to Martin and explained to them that I
was going to have to move and Surround
too and then I went to Martin and and
Sheamus and and John and you know we
were okay we were prepared to move that
I came back to the funeral back up again
and then we just stayed at it non-stop
when we look at that I'm not going to
repeat the issues but the issues were
huge and the issues were huge on your
side Tony you used to face a huge amount
of prisoners and the outdoor form of the
right lots of course wage huge issues
and the Constitution sideways but I
think the big breakthroughs you know
if you the trick of it all
was that if we could get the
Constitutional issues off the table
and that was changing the government
Ireland act section 75
which will really set up Northern
Ireland also taking the art of the
student tree off the table
getting the principle of consent on the
table that that was the only change and
I think we should always remember that
the balance of the agreement is hugely
important because that was the balance
and that still is the balance which made
Northern Ireland different to anywhere
else in the United Kingdom and people
should always remember remember that
going forward and so
um that delicate balance once we achieve
that I found them that you know
certainly with the unionists
um Martha remembered the late night
meeting with David Trimble and where
Shameless Mallon I never saw them so
emotional when they got strand too out
of the way we didn't have a difficult
with strand no Degas around one and we I
turned around two we had no difficulties
to entry and we started making progress
and then of course things came up at the
end
um and Tony Blair had to start writing
side letters and Jonathan pal put them
in under the door because nobody had
answered the door but anyway
um at least and then David Trimble got
opened the table to say I'm with your
room I mean we're amazing things but the
compromises along the way but I have to
say your Tony is nice and we're about to
say this to you Tony some of those
decisions in the last 36 hours you're
making those on your own
of reference back to your cabinet there
were huge decisions they brought peace
you have to call them and there were big
calls and they will juggle them
[Applause]
so we're getting toward the end I
personally could go on for a long time
but I think we should stay within the
the time limits given to us and so Bill
I want to start with
um your Recollections of the end I do
remember all those late night phone
calls
um
they they were pretty uh pretty constant
and always at three or four o'clock in
the morning as I recall but if you could
just
share a bill with you know as you're
thinking about the end but also then I
want to segue starting uh with you as to
what advice
if any would you give to political
leaders and active citizens and the
people of Northern Ireland right now in
terms of you know moving forward uh into
the next 25 years and then I'll ask
Bertie and and with Tony on that same
question
well first of all the
the last week was horrible for me
for me because I was so full of
anticipation
and I had a day job
and I was so jealous
of Tony and Bernie
I felt almost as if I were about to
Hillary were about to give birth to our
second child and they got to go to the
waiting room
and I was kept out
but you know George Mitchell would call
me that Tony would call me and I'd talk
to Barry and we
got to tell whoever I was asked to call
but
the thing that I felt always
was
the process
of which
all the parties had proceeded it
involved so much time so much effort and
was done with so much respect for people
across the political Spectrum
that I thought at the end
these people wouldn't walk away
yeah I just it sort of
it's a great tribute to all of them I I
also there are people who haven't been
Mary immaculais and Michael here I I
think the presidency of Ireland I'm glad
Ireland has a symbolic president
who can
bring people together
and it's a metaphor that they had a
president from Northern Ireland
I would
I don't know I don't want to get in the
way of the problem Hillary but I think
you ought to ask all the people who are
here
who've had any part of that peace
business then to stand up because a lot
of them survive and they're here is that
okay would you all stand up Mark said
[Applause]
thank you
how's your might have the Tony and worry
about the one last thing I want to say
is I think
the women's groups the other peace
groups
the people who weren't always in the
rooms all those kids that became public
figures by the speeches they gave
pleading
for people to give them a safe future
I think they had an impact on people
I think every one of us
wound up being a little better than we
would have been otherwise
because we had to look at the eyes of
people and I think
I wish that every trolled area of the
world
there was some way to bring that human
dimension in the way it was in the
northern Irish peace process because
it does affect you
a lot of these people make a decisions
you know they're parents
or their children their brothers their
sisters that died
I think it would be a mistake for us to
underestimate
the power
of their influence
well Chancellor Hillary but my one
bit of advice we we worked really hard
all of us collectively
and you know your president gave so much
time and effort you came to Northern
Ireland to decided to find more times
than you know you could be anywhere in
the world and you know Tony and his
governments and successive governments
have given huge time and commitment and
between 1998 and the 13th of October
2006 we worked really really hard to get
um Democratic Juniors partying outside
and to move with us up to that may 2007
when we we kind of felt we got our job
done you know orders have to finish it
on and I just just really plead and
deeply hope
and that the Democratic unionist party
will you know pay their War back to
myself to stay the road with us because
and the people of Northern Ireland need
them I think the people in this island
need them we all want to work together
the alternatives are not good don't even
think about them so let's hope they
listen to what George Mitchell said
today and this is what we're saying that
we all just get back from the track
there's too many big things to be
dealing with than to be arguing about
um some detail that must cause
oversolded or another which I'm not sure
what it is either so
thank you
[Applause]
so so just let's move forward and try
and make this work
Tony
I think we
just very briefly we
we know the piece isn't perfect
we know the institutions have often been
Rocky and unstable as they are today
and we know there's still a lot of
distrust and mistrust between the
communities
but we also know the Northern Ireland is
a much better place
than it was before the Good Friday
agreement
and the only thing I would say to
today's leaders is I think when you
stand back and you reflect
you
you know in your heart of hearts what
the right thing to do is
and you should just get on and do it
[Applause]
thank you so much
thank you
[Applause]
well what a fantastic finale to the day
thank you all very much it's a wonderful
panel
it's been a very emotional and
thought-provoking day but this brings
the day to a close I'm sure you're all
leaving with plenty of food for thought
and I hope that you find today's session
stimulating and interesting if you're
returning tomorrow we look forward to
seeing you then thank you and good
evening
that's awesome